pour les élections européennes les
républicains se sont choisi un
professeur de philosophie est ce que ce
sera suffisant pour ramener vers la
droite une partie des électeurs qui sont
partis notamment du côté de la
république en marche
on va commencer par les gilet jaune 23
mille six cents manifestants hier le
chiffre le plus bas depuis le début du
mouvement selon me serres de l'intérieur
24e samedi de manifestations cinq mois
de mobile homes en est dans tous les
désordres auxquels nous avons assisté au
cours des dernières semaines il y à
l'occasion d'une fracturation sociale
très forte pour notre pays l'occasion
aussi d'une paralysie pour beaucoup de
nos centres villes et n'arrivent pas à
s'en sortir et je le vois depuis le
début de cette campagne partout en
france le poids de la fiscalité qui pèse
sur nos entreprises sur le travail le
poids des charges
tout cela fait qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
de français dans tous les territoires de
france se donne beaucoup de mal et ne
parviennent pas à joindre les deux bouts
laurent et ça évidemment ça pose un
problème rend vous qui en gilet jaune je
disais vous l'aviez jamais remis mi même
c'était une erreur
non mais c'était une manière d'aller
parler avec des gens qui témoignaient de
leur angoisse et cette angoisse et c'est
là qu'il faut entendre c'est quand même
incroyable que donc chaque année mais ce
que je veux dire on en vient de vendre
vous et laurent wauquiez chacun son
style sur le gilet jaune
moi j'ai pas été j'ai pas j'ai pas été
dans la même situation que laurent
wauquiez il allait écouter ces personnes
c'était très influent je les crois de se
mettre à leur écoute et d'ailleurs on
n'en serait pas là aujourd'hui si le
gouvernement avait su entendre plus tôt
cette inquiétude et cette angoisse qui
traverse notre pays
il aurait était si facile
malheureusement d'éviter ces semaines de
grands débats qui ont coûté très cher et
qui ont été l'occasion d'une mise en
scène médiatique si facile d'éviter
cette tension et cette crise profonde
que notre pays traverse si on avait été
dialoguer avec ces personnes pour
essayer d'entendre leur cri de révolte
en danse épisode au point d'arrivée le
blick des appels à manifester ont été
lancés pour mercredi prochain 1er mai
lac ultime s'est baptisé comme ça avez
vous des craintes
oui parce qu'on a le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement nous
n'arrivons pas ou en tous les cas que le
gouvernement ne parvient pas à maintenir
l'ordre
ce qui est quand même la première
responsabilité de tout gouvernement
maintenir l'ordre et la concorde entre
les citoyens
ça fait deux semaines que aujourd'hui
nous avons le sentiment d'assister à
l'impuissance de l'état comme ça a été
le cas déjà à notre dame des landes au
début du quinquennat le sentiment que
l'état recule devant le désordre
installé il faut enfin que cela cesse et
qu'on donne à nos forces de l'ordre les
moyens de rétablir enfin
l'ordre et la paix dont nous avons
besoin il y aura ou pas unis ce gilet
jaune aux élections européennes ce
serait une bonne chose qu'il y ait des
députés européens français gilet jaune
c'est toujours une bonne chose que les
français s'expriment dans la vie
électorale mais non mais qu'il y ait des
députés européens français gilet jaune
qui arrive avec vous le même jour à la
rentrée au parlement européen à
strasbourg c'est toujours une bonne
chose que les français s'expriment dans
une échéance électorale
en revanche ce qui est sûr c'est que je
crois pas qu'on puisse faire de la
politique uniquement à partir d'une
revendication particulière et c c'est
aussi peut-être un peu la fragilité de
ce grand débat dans lequel le président
engagé notre pays c'est que la politique
ça consiste à proposer un cap global une
vision d'ensemble cette élection
européenne elle suppose de proposer une
vision d'ensemble pour l'avenir de
l'europe et nous nous entendons cette
colère des gilets jaunes nous
l'entendons d'autant mieux d'ailleurs
que elle correspond exactement au
diagnostic de notre famille politique à
porter mais pour qu'elle se fasse
entendre il vaut mieux qu'il y ait des
députés gilet jaune
ce serait une façon de se faire entendre
encore une fois comme je voulais dit
plus il y aura de français qui
participeront maintenant c'est bien sûr
des députés gilet jaune mais ce que je
crois c'est qu'on peut pas réduire
voyez la revendication des gilets jaunes
elle s'est faite autour d'une
revendication
on peut pas réduire un projet et le
littoral à une seule revendication
la question n'est pas de savoir s'il
faut augmenter ou baisser tel ou tel
impôt la question c'est quelle est la
stratégie pour demain
la stratégie économique notre nos
stratégies du coup en matière de
fiscalité essayer de cette vision dont
nous avons cruellement besoin alors on
va revenir sur les annonces des manuels
macron d'après gantés de grands débats
qui ont été l'un des temps forts de la
semaine
emmanuel macron dit avoir entendu la
grogne de ces derniers mois mais il le
martèle il ne changera pas de cap
je me suis posé la question est ce qu'on
a fait fausse route
je crois tout le contraire dans cet
exercice il reconnaît même quelques
erreurs personnelles sur son style sur
des mots qu'il a pu prononcer et qui ont
pu heurter
l'impatience l'exigence que j'ai avec
moi même que j'ai avec les membres du
gouvernement je mets un peu mieux avec
les français et donc le sentiment que
j'ai donnés c'était semble d'injonction
permanente d'être dur parfois injuste ça
je le regrette la suppression de 120
mille postes de fonctionnaires n'est
plus une priorité
le président souhaite que plus une école
ni un hôpital ne ferme sans l'avis du
maire en tout 24 élèves par classe ça
tombe bien parce qu'ils sont en train
d'en fermer l'une ici emmanuel macron a
souligné sa volonté de ne pas toucher à
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite même
s'il veut inciter à travailler plus
regarder si on peut allonger la période
de référence sans bouger l'âge légal
pour avoir un système de décote qui
incite à travailler davantage
il souhaite aussi l'instauration d'une
pension minimum la question la pension
minimum du régime général pour les
retraités va passer de 637 euros à 1000
euros nets c'est un petit plus qui
ferait du bien
immigration europe laïcité le président
veut d'abord refonder l'espace schengen
et remettre à plat la politique
migratoire pour être ouvert il faut
avoir des limites pour accueillir il
faut avoir une maison
donc il faut des frontières face à la
menace du communautarisme
emmanuel macron veut enfin protéger la
laïcité pour lui un danger un seul
l'islam politique
peu de choses concrètes sur la
transition écologique sujet sur lequel
ils étaient pourtant attendus on se gave
y avait l'âme il ya eu un mea culpa d'
emmanuel macron là sur son style de
gouvernance il a dit j'ai peut-être été
trop brutal parfois trop direct c'est un
mea culpa bienvenus ce qui est bien
c'est qu'il faut savoir effectivement
reconnaître ses erreurs je pense qu'on a
tout à gagner dans le fait de partager
une langue politiques qu'ils soient plus
simple et plus franches
ah non je crois pas que les français en
veille d'abord à emmanuel macron pour
quelques petites phrases malheureuses
au fond ce qu'on attendait d'abord de
cette conférence de presse c'était la
voir enfin un cap clair pour l'avenir
des décisions courageuses et
malheureusement de ce point de vue là je
n'ai pas tout à fait l'impression que
nous soyons sortis du brûler vous dites
que vous les français n'en veulent pas
et emmanuel macron sûr si tu veut du
boulot tu traverses la rue ceux qui
foutent le bordel les français n'en
veulent pas au président de la
république forte sans aucun doute
maladroit et c'était très bien qu'il
exprime ses regrets mais ce qui est
attendu d'abord du président de la
république c'est pas des excuses ou des
regrets pour quelques mots maladroits
c'est d'abord de pouvoir faire en sorte
qu'on sorte enfin de cette paralysie
dans laquelle notre pays semble
désormais installée alors on disait tout
à l'heure qu'il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
dans le domaine de l'écologie alors que
c'est une des revendications des
français ou des attentes des français
pour ces élections européennes
cependant emmanuel macron a rappelé
qu'il fallait changer de modèle face à
l'urgence climatique
à vos yeux est ce qu'il ya urgence
climatique il y a bien sûr une urgence
écologique global qu'est ce qu'il faut
changer
il faut bien sûr changer de modèle dans
la mondialisation est d'ailleurs le
débat européen et le débat pour cela
parce que rééquilibrer la mondialisation
ça suppose de faire en sorte que
l'europe puisse de nouveau assumer de
produire ce que nous consommons
ce qui veut dire défendre nos frontières
défendre nos entreprises et nos emplois
pour garder une économie qui nous permet
effectivement de continuer à produire
aujourd'hui on vit dans une
mondialisation débridée où toute
l'industrie se fait en asie et nous ne
produirions plus que des commerces ou
des services il faut évidemment qu'on
sorte de cette logique là ça c'est votre
réponse au genre et l'écologie le monde
de demain
c'est votre réponse aux enjeux
écologiques que c'est une réponse
majeure prenant un exemple très concret
aujourd'hui a quasiment plus aucune
capacité de traitement du poisson en
europe c'est un exemple que je prends
souvent parce qu'il est très parlant
dire que quand vous pêcher un poisson en
norvège et qu'il doit être traité pour
devenir un plat préparé vous l'emmenez
en chine généralement pour être traité
et il revient en france pour être
consommés il a fait des milliers de
kilomètres avant d'arriver dans votre
assiette
et on voudrait nous faire croire que le
problème climatique est dû uniquement à
l'ouvrier aux salariés français qui a
besoin de sa voiture pour faire 10 km
pour aller travailler
si on ne met pas fin à cette
mondialisation débridée si on installe
pas une vraie barrière écologique à
l'entrée du marché européen pour faire
en sorte effectivement de favoriser une
production qui permettent de retrouver
cet équilibre écologique alors on n'aura
rien fait pour s'attaquer à la cause de
l'accès un exemple concret un autre
exemple concret le glyphosate par
exemple l'union européenne veut
l'interdire dans cinq ans est ce qu'il
faut aller plus vite il faut qu'on
puisse l'interdire quand on aura trouvé
une solution de transition dont il n'y a
pas de délai paumé l'asra
gilles l'union européenne elle est bonne
parce qu'elle permet de préparer cette
stratégie de transition
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
interdire le glyphosate immédiatement
comme le propose emmanuel macron avec
une plus brève échéance bien monsieur
canfin qui est numéro deux sur la liste
dans marche interdire le glyphosate
immédiatement ça n'est pas sortir du
glyphosate
c'est juste importer des produits faits
avec du glyphosate parce qu'aujourd'hui
on ne sait pas produire sans ces
produits phytosanitaires est donc
évidemment il faut une transition
les agriculteurs sont les premiers
concernés je crois que nous avons
d'ailleurs en france l'agriculture qui
appliquent les standards les plus élevés
au monde avec vous le dvg cinq ans c'est
le bon mais ne ne pas le faire avec un
peu de pragmatisme c'est en fait
simplement tiré une balle dans le pied
nos agriculteurs et favoriser une
production écologiquement - elle le
délai de cinq ans c'est le bon le délai
de 5 ans et celui qui de l'avis des
chercheurs permet donc pour varier le
bon ces alternatives crédibles vous
preniez seulement pascal canfin numéro
deux de la liste la république envers
sida une question qui nous a envoyé pour
vous bonjour les associations
environnementales européennes ont
accordé la note de 3 sur 20 au vote des
députés européens de votre groupe
politique depuis cinq ans sur le climat
en 2018 ces mêmes associations ont placé
la france dans le top 3 des pays les
plus ambitieux dans la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
monsieur bel ami comment expliquez vous
comment justifiez-vous la médiocrité de
cette note 3 sur 20 sur un sujet qui est
pourtant aussi déterminant pour l'avenir
de nos enfants et de nos petits-enfants
que la lutte contre les dérèglements
climatiques
je vous réponds alors au salut je suis
enseignant donc la question quand on met
une note c'est de savoir qui mais la
note et on peut être en désaccord sur la
meilleure manière de relever ce grand
défi climatique qui effectivement est
devant nous parce que vous remettez en
cause qui met la note mais les
associations environnementales ont le
droit d'avoir leur avis et je reconnais
à monsieur qu'enfin la légitimité
d'avoir son point de vue mais ça n'est
pas le nôtre effectivement des lobbys
pour vous nous ne sommes pas des
idéologues et de l'écologie et nous font
les lobbys pour vous les associations
ont vu là ce sont des groupes de
d'influents ce qui je crois sont très
présents au parlement européen et qui
ont une vision précise de la manière
dont cette transition écologique selon
elle devrait se produire
nous n'avons pas forcément la même
vision de croyants et une écologie
pragmatique et reprenons l'exemple du
glyphosate ça ne sert à rien de se fixer
des normes qu'on ne peut pas respecter
si ensuite c'est effectivement pour
favoriser une production écologiquement
moins vertueuses prenons un exemple tout
simple
si la france a une si bonne note
prie monsieur qu enfin en matière de
production d'une énergie moins carbonée
c'est peut-être grâce à l'énergie
nucléaire que monsieur qu'enfin lui même
combat et l'envoyer au fond il faut
regarder les choses avec un peu de
pragmatisme
ça ne veut pas dire que nous ne soyons
pas convaincu de la nécessité de prendre
en compte le défi écologique et je crois
que le ppe notre famille politique a
fait beaucoup pour cela je pense par
exemple à l'interdiction de la pêche
électrique qui a été mené en particulier
par alain cadec qui est sur notre liste
n'est pas crétin c'est pas que tous les
groupes là pour l'environnement c'est
une équipe cadette a été vraiment moteur
dans ce dans une émigration
l'immigration c'est aussi votre sujet et
emmanuel macron vous avez entendu là
tout à l'heure a dit que pour bien
accueillir
il faut des frontières on a l'impression
de vous entendre c'est vrai que c'était
frappant de l'entendre dire des mots qui
condamné hier et des mots que pour le
coup nous disons
aujourd'hui c'est une bonne chose de
voir quand
on reconnaît que pour accueillir
quelqu'un chez soi comme je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs sur ce plateau même chez sur
trois il ya quelques mois de cela pour
accueillir quelqu'un chez soi il faut
effectivement avoir un chez soi
donc en fait il vous rejoint emmanuel
macron pas tout à fait parce qu'en
réalité derrière les mots il ya les
actes et monsieur macron depuis qu'il
est au pouvoir la france n'a jamais
accueilli profondément fracturé par des
tensions communautaires
je crois que nous n'avons pas le droit à
une telle irresponsabilité il faut
mettre fin à l'immigration mais c'est à
dire il va concevoir schengen il faut
revoir les accords de dublin qui
organise l'accueil des réfugiés qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire nous nous avons une
stratégie très claire et nous sommes les
seuls d'ailleurs à la proposer
contrairement au rassemblement national
ne croyons pas que devant l'ampleur du
défi qui est devant nous sur le plan de
l'immigration que nous serons plus forts
tout seul et donc oui c'est vrai nous
voulons une stratégie européenne pour
défendre les frontières extérieures de
l'europe mais ça passe par quoi ça passe
par le fait d'avoir par exemple une et
puis deuxièmement ça passe aussi par le
fait d'offrir à chaque état les moyens
de maîtriser sa politique migratoire
ce que nous dit monsieur macron et il
l'a redit dans sa conférence de presse
il ya quelques jours c'est qu'il faut
installer une politique de quotas dans
l'espace schengen monsieur macron a dit
qu'il voulait sortir de schengen tous
les pays qui n'assumait pas la
solidarité ça veut dire que pour
monsieur mâcon ce qui compte c'est de se
répartir une immigration qu'on n'a pas
su maîtriser
nous ne voulons pas continuer à subir
cette intuition qu'il faudra réviser
l'accord de dublin
il faut faire en sorte que l'accord de
dublin ne soit plus l'occasion de
renvoyer se changer ça passe par le
règlement de dublin mais plus
profondément encore ça passe par le fait
le règlement de dublin soyons très
concret il dit que c'est le pays de
premier arrivé qui doit traiter un
migrant quand il est arrivé en haut
deux familles la droite chez nous
est ce que c'est de famille oui c'est
plutôt de famille tout à fait j'aurais
pu être belle
c'était pas mon tempérament
ça fait très narcissique de ses dires
soi même j'avoue que j'ai eu un petit
moment de recul en envoyant la tête sur
les kiosques à journaux et je me suis un
peu demandé ce qui était en train de
m'arriver en alsace mais voici un nom
même de centimètres par an en juin
qui a voulu que je sois investi je
comprends parfaitement que
on n'est pas été immédiatement convaincu
van tête de liste pour la droite il me
semble qu'il ya eu des élections dans un
an pour les allemands soient dangereux
pour les français il apporte de l'envié
il apporte sa fraîcheur il n'ya pas que
ces conventions
ça me fait plaisir
savez en fait quand je regarde quelle
est la seule liste européenne qui a une
dynamique
c'est là notre mieux avec toi c'est
gentil merci j'ai déjà rencontré je les
ai déjà entendu cette pratique merveille
c'est un plaisir c'est un bonheur de
l'entendre
pour moi c'est le sauveur de la droite
c'est le sourire de la france
qu'est ce qui vous plaît chez lui c'est
son côté tac tout paraissait est aisé
vous le versailles et est ce que vous
pensez être le candidat idéal pour
séduire la droite populaire qui pour
l'instant vous manque alors d'abord je
suis pas sûr d'être le candidat idéal je
me suis beaucoup posé la question avant
d'accepter cette mission qui m'était
proposé par laurent wauquiez par toute
cette famille politique j'ai été très
touché de cette confiance qui m'a été
témoignée est ce que je crois c'est que
c'est d'abord une aventure d'equipe j'ai
été investi dès le début avec allié avec
agnès et brink et vice-président de la
région ile-de-france avec arnaud danjean
qui est un eurodéputé sortant
il ya un vrai lien d'amitié qui s'est
créée entre nous et et avec tous ceux
qui nous ont rejoints sur cette liste on
porte ensemble ayant la corde sans
l'alliance il y en a d'autres sur l'a10
nadine morano brice hortefeux par
exemple c'est vous qui les avez choisi
non c'est d'abord la liste d'une famille
vous les assumez la lisent le fait la
liste de laurent duthe ils furent que la
route c'est pas moi qui les ai choisis
c'est toute notre famille politique la
commission d'investiture mais je crois
que c'est très important aussi vous
savez moi j'ai jamais cru à l'opposition
de l'ancien et du nouveau monde jamais
cru quatre jeunes c'était forcément être
meilleur à nos aînés meilleurs que nos
aînés ce qui compte c'est la
complémentarité entre l'expérience et le
renouvellement ce que nos amis allemands
savent très bien faire au parlement
européen ce sont des institutions
complexe on peut pas arriver avec tous
ensemble vous aller siéger donc au
parlement européen avec l'acier des ou
qui est le parti d'angela merkel ce
parti là il ne veut plus entendre parler
du siège européen à strasbourg
vous allez défendre la capitale
alsacienne
mais jusqu'où est ce que vous êtes prêts
à aller jusqu'au clash avec nos
partenaires allemands
bien sûr nous défendrons le siège
européen de strasbourg d'ailleurs si
nous considérons que l'alternance entre
bruxelles et strasbourg est trop
compliqué nous proposons d'installer le
siège du parlement européen à strasbourg
il seulement à strasbourg
comme vous le savez de toute façon le
siège de strasbourg est inscrit dans les
traités parce que strasbourg
c'est une grande ville de l'europe c'est
une ville qui a connu tous les désastres
des dernières décennies de la vie de
notre continent
c'est l'avis aussi qui a connu ce que
l'europe a fait deux plus grandes plus
beau mais dans l'histoire de la culture
c'est notre dame de strasbourg
cette cathédrale de la ville de marle et
les allemands qui eux la cdu
vous êtes un quiz nous on veut brûler
les cno également nous avons parfois des
désaccords et il faut que les français
sachent que le parlement européen c'est
aussi le lieu où parfois on exprime ses
désaccords il faut que la voix de la
france puisse peser et moi ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup vous savez c'est que
dans cette lettre qui a été écrite par
les grecs comme karine bauraud pointe
dans de la république avec l'assentiment
d'angela merkel dans cette lettre on
voit tout l'affaiblissement de la france
dans le dialogue européen
emmanuel macron avait promis qu'il
ferait de l'europe le centre de gravité
de son action politique malheureusement
il a réussi à isoler la france comme
jamais une chose je reste dans les
questions de taille parce que vous
n'avez pas répondu est ce que vous êtes
prêt à aller au clash avec vos
partenaires allemands sur cette question
du siège du parlement européen allait
nous irons jusqu'au bout et de fait pour
que le siège de strasbourg soit
abandonnée il faudrait une révision des
traités ce qui veut dire l'unanimité
évidemment non jamais nous ne serons
d'accord pour renoncer aussi à lui même
avec vos partenaires et nous tenons
beaucoup à ce que l'alsace reste le
coeur battant de la vie parlementaire
n'a pas dit un mot sur le in sur le
parti de viktor orban qui vous savez a
été suspendu du ppe donc le parti
populaire européen jusqu'en juin repas
de noël à droite européenne après juin
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ce que vous
sentez est-ce que vous souhaiter qu'il
soit réintégré
moi je souhaite bien sûr que le ppe
puisse continuer d'avancer avec toutes
les familles politiques avec nous
ordonne le fides est un parti politique
hongrois qui a été l'un des pionniers de
la lutte contre le communisme soviétique
on ne peut pas se couper de ce parti qui
fait parti du ppe depuis plusieurs
décennies
il faut qu'on puisse avoir effectivement
un dialogue constructif sur la meilleure
manière us à la mairie gration je
souhaite en tous les cas qu'on évite le
risque de fracturation qui menacent
leurs primes accordées je vous le pose
autrement est ce que vous souhaitez sa
réintégration bien sûr je souhaite qu'on
puisse se mettre d'accord sur ce qui
définit le ppe et faire en sorte qu'à
partir de cet accord rien on puisse
avancer ensemble
legrand à réduire le grand risque
aujourd'hui qui guette l'europe c'est
celui de cette fracture que le clivage
mac renier entre populiste et
progressistes voudrait installer celui
de cette fracture qui viendrait faire
basculer l'europe dans un clivage qui
rendrait le dialogue impossible d'éditer
et le ppe le groupe ppe vous pourriez le
présider personnellement vous êtes
candidat
non moi je suis d'abord vous savez les
institutions européennes sans
institutions complexe et j'arrive dans
ce débat avec une grande humilité nappe
j'ai beaucoup à apprendre de ce qui me
précède dont vous n'êtes pas leur a dit
d'aller
pépé par le massif sur sur françois
fillon qui vous a apporté son soutien
c'est à lui que vous devez l'état de
votre parti actuellement donc son
soutien c'est quoi c'est un boulet ou
c'est une chance pour vous non je crois
que l'état de notre parti ont le doit
d'abord à beaucoup d'années de
difficultés parfois d'erreurs parfois
deux divisions stériles et de querelles
inutiles et aujourd'hui ce qui compte
c'est de se tourner vers l'avenir
je suis très touché de recevoir le
soutien de beaucoup de figures de notre
famille les deux nicolas sarkozy pour
l'instant vous l'attendez j'ai
l'occasion d'échanger régulièrement avec
nicolas sarkozy je n'ai pas de je n'ai
pas eu l'occasion de rencontrer françois
fillon mais j'ai été touché
effectivement de ce message doublé de
nicolas sarkozy vous espérez son soutien
au 6 mai nicolas sarkozy encore une fois
on a eu l'occasion d'échanger en mai
vous l'aurez son soutien mais je crois
qu'il ya aucune ambiguïté sur le fait
que nicolas sarkozy qui est une des
figures importantes de cette famille
politique qui a été président de la
république de notre de notre famille
politique est toujours profondément lié
à la droite qui le regarde avec
attention
françois-xavier bellamy pour l'instant
c'est vrai que le grand public vous
connaît assez peu hein on sait que vous
avez soutenu la création de ambre en
tous les cas entourent encourager la
création de sens commun on sait donc que
vous avez soutenu françois fillon mais
pour le second tour de la présidentielle
vous avez voté pour qui j'ai déjà
répondu à cette question et déjà répondu
que je ne je ne répondrai pas à cette
question parce que c'est au fond je
crois
il faut assumer les choix qu'on fait
quand ce sont des choix ya joué ces
votes quand on est responsable de
déterminant j'ai assumé parfaitement les
engagements que j'ai pris effectivement
par exemple dans le débat de l'élection
présidentielle
mais vous voyez le grand le grand
problème de notre vie démocratique
aujourd'hui c'est le risque qui se
produirait si on en venait à ce second
tour perpétuel entre populiste et
progressistes entre monsieur macro eux
mêmes le pen qui n'offrent pas une
véritable alternative et je sais très
bien ce qu'il ya derrière cette question
ce qui est derrière cette question c'est
la volonté de dire à chacun qu'il faut
choisir son camp
c'est bien sinon vous aurez une façon
nouvelle et régionales nous voulons
offrir une alternative crédible tout ce
dernier s'était notamment biais de
livres 20 secondes de mes positions
vous êtes sans l'ombre des républicains
aujourd'hui vous allez avoir une place
un peu plus important dans ce parc est
ce que vous avez envie de rentrer dans
la direction du parti
non j'espère pouvoir contribuer à mon
humble mesure dans cette campagne à
reconstruire la confiance autour de
cette famille politique en on
besoin je crois d'aller de nouveau au
contact des français et pour moi ce qui
compte c'est d'être chaque jour pendant
les trente jours qui restent en campagne
sur le terrain pour aller écouter ce
qu'ils ont à nous dire à leur proposer
ce projet que nous voulons pour l'avenir
merci nathalie les deux poteaux dimanche
en politique les élections législatives
en espagne parce que l'ambition des
républicains c'est de mettre une droite
pour reprendre cette expression à tous
vos concurrents et en espagne un autre
enjeu là un mois des européennes c'est
que l'extrême droite vox pourrait entrer
au parlement première fois depuis 1982
est ce que ça vous inquiète
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on voit
aujourd'hui à quel point les les
renoncements et les déceptions
accumulées constitue l'occasion d'un
ressentiment très fort ça vous inquiète
la classe politique et donc oui c'est
une inquiétude que ce ressentiment se
manifeste au fond qu'est ce qui se passe
en espagne aujourd'hui j'ai changé sur
ce sujet là avec la tête de liste
espagnole de lloret seconde ceyrat qui
est membre du parti populaire de la
famille politique de la droite classique
espagnole cette famille politique elle
elle voit aujourd'hui la difficulté dans
laquelle se trouve le débat démocratique
espagnole paralysé par la question
catalan la difficulté à offrir
précisément une alternative et les
erreurs du gouvernement socialiste qui
provoque cette réaction et la montée de
la cause des socialistes et des catalans
donc si je vous comprends bien il ya
tous les cas aujourd'hui c'est vrai de
la part du gouvernement socialiste avec
pourtant la faible légitimité qu'il a
aujourd'hui du fait ça de son de la
manière dont il est arrivé au pouvoir
une politique par exemple typiquement à
ses inconséquences sur les questions
migratoires qui provoque effet et sur
l'a14 j'ai entendu et sur la catalogne
et sur la catalogne aussi tout à fait
aujourd'hui c'est la journée de la
déportation en france avec des
cérémonies partout en france et la face
noire de l'histoire de l'europe
l'allemagne nazie est ce que cette
journée pourrait devenir une journée
européenne il faudrait qu'elle le
devienne bien sûr vous souhaitez vous
mes lignes allaient faire une
proposition était là nous nous proposons
de défendre une action européenne
concertée sur la question dans simitis
parce que c'est très important que tous
les états européens parlent d'une seule
voix et je le dis avec d'autant plus de
gravité qu'on vient de vivre cette
tuerie qui a eu lieu aux états unis hier
dans une synagogue près de san diego qui
a fait un mort une femme et et trois
blessés et je crois que lutter contre
l'antisémitisme c'est un enjeu
fondamental pour notre avenir c'est pas
seulement la page noire de l'histoire
c'est aussi
une menace qui nous guettent encore
c'est peut être une journée européenne
vous l'avait dit pour terminer vraiment
dans la quelques secondes
les parents de vincent lambert cet homme
qui est rappelée gic dans un état
végétatif depuis dix ans vont saisir la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pour demander l'interruption des
traitements sur leurs fils est ce que
vous les soutenez
je crois que ce qui compte c'est de
respecter effectivement la dignité
humaine et est malheureusement
aujourd'hui les militant de l'euthanasie
fondu cas de vincent lambert l'occasion
de lutter pour faire en sorte qu'on ne
reconnaissent plus comme un homme celui
qui est seulement prisonniers de cette
maladie qui le qui le touche
je vous les soutenez non pardon vous
soutenez les parents de vincent lambert
je soutiens ceux qui luttent pour que
vincent lambert puisse rester en vie
continuait d'être soignés comme ils le
méritent comme il le doit merci françois
xavier villain vie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans dimanche en politique et
on retrouve matin catherine matausch
pour écouter da mi journée